>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Anne McLean: Good evening.
I'm Anne McLean from the
Library's Concert Office.
My colleague, David Plylar
and I have the great pleasure
of talking with Kristian
Bezuidenhout tonight.
Welcome back to the Library.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Thank you.
>> Anne McLean: It's exciting
for us to have you here again.
The program we had him here,
fortunately, the last time,
maybe one or two
of you heard it,
was with the [foreign
language] an all-Haydn evening.
And I think you created that.
Right? You put it
together with part songs.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: Yes.
And it was a kind of dramatical
program that was the kind
of narrative of part songs, solo
keyboard sonatas and solo songs,
originally mixed in
with readings as well.
But we didn't do the
readings, I guess,
in the concert version here.
It was a wonderful program.
It ended up being a
wonderful program.
>> Anne McLean: It was.
I was listening it.
We have a recording of it.
I was just checking
it out the other day.
Very special.
Tonight you will be performing
both Haydn and Beethoven.
So, everyone on our
staff has been watching
over the years since that time.
The raves that Kristian has
been receiving as a master
of three instruments,
harpsichord,
forte piano, and piano.
The London Times calls
you the most brilliant
of today's forte pianos with a
claim for a consummate command
of the possibilities of
the instrument really.
And critics comment
that he creates magic.
So, we're looking forward now
to chatting with you about some
of your magical skills.
Your prestidigitation.
And learning a little bit about
the works we'll here and also
about the instrument
we'll hear tonight.
So, with that, maybe since
probably several of us have some
of your Mozart recordings, maybe
we could start by talking to you
about this multi, multi-volume
set that you've made
and your obsession with Mozart.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
People often ask me
where this comes from.
And over the course of
many interviews I've had
to just really admit,
quite honestly,
that for me the big
watershed moment,
was Amadeus, the film actually.
I must have seen it
when I was about 8 or 9.
Nine probably.
Because I remember very
distinctly that some
of the scenes my
parents shielded me from.
The first scene where
Salieri tries to kill himself.
But I still think it's
the greatest film made
about a composer,
regardless of any
of the historical
quibbles one might have.
I think it's arguably the
greatest film about a composer.
Because Peter Shaffer was
absolutely insistent on the fact
that one of the central
characters
in the film would be
Mozart's music, in fact.
And I think unlike any
other film about a composer,
the role the music plays
in that film is portrayed
with such honor and reverence,
in a sense, and also the taste
that went into choosing
the best moments,
musically speaking,
in that film.
I look back now and
see the film,
and I realize that's what
really struck me about it.
And just this -- the music
somehow spoke to me so deeply,
very subconsciously,
unconsciously.
[Inaudible comment] Yes.
I realized at the time that my
parents had played a huge amount
of music in the house when I
was 2, 3, 4, 5, really at an age
when I wasn't able to say, oh,
that's the Mozart
big g minor symphony.
Or that's Figaro cosa
[assumed spelling] e.
But hearing this
music in the film,
you realize that your
childhood memories ingrained
in you then come to the surface.
It was a very strong moment
of connection on that level.
And after that, I was
completely obsessed.
I wouldn't listen to
anything but Mozart.
My parents loved Bach
and Beethoven, as well.
But I was very single minded.
[Laughter] And around
that time Phillips brought
out the complete Mozart edition
in time for the 91 celebrations.
And that was, I mean, that
was the only thing I cared
about in my whole life
was having that set.
And of course, my
parents realized
that it was ridiculously
expensive.
But it -- the man and the music
and the myths surrounding him
and the fact that it was
the celebration year.
I also discovered quite a lot
of recordings of his music
at that time that changed
my life forever, as well.
And it was a sort of perfect
storm of timing and a situation.
>> David Plylar: Your first
recording was actually
an all-Mozart.
Just outside the Harmonia Mundi.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
That's right.
It was huge.
Not many people know
about that album.
It was a volume of old
Mozart keyboard works,
and specifically old
Mozart in minor keys.
I wanted to -- the disc
is called [inaudible]
and I was 20 years old.
And just had the mad idea
about how this thing would go.
I recorded the disc in one day.
Which I don't know how --
I really don't know
how I did that.
I would die now, I think,
if I had to do that.
But the idea was
it had a red cover.
Every piece was in a minor key.
I was trying to portray
a Mozart who was inspired
by the [foreign language]
movement of the middle
of the 18th century, even
if you don't think that's
a real musical movement.
It's very clear that something
is in the water around that time
that inspires people like Haydn.
And later, I think, Mozart
emulating Haydn to write music
of uncommon stress and violence
and rhetorical extremity.
And, you know, it can't
be any coincidence
that they're all doing this
somewhat at the same time.
They're choosing pieces in --
writing pieces in keys
like G minor consistently.
And this very angular,
somewhat tempestuous music comes
out of these guys and is later,
I think Mozart then later
replicates this style
in honor of that.
But I wanted to show a
side of Mozart's character
that was the furthest
thing away from this kind
of genteel elevator music
that his music can turn into,
particularly his keyboard
music if not treated
with the right kind of
combination of intensity
and unlocking, maybe let's
say, hidden layers of meaning
or detail that are not
necessarily conveyed
by the specificity
of the notation.
I put it that way.
But, yes, that's right.
That was the very
first album, David.
>> Anne McLean: Though
you develop
in your [inaudible] conveyed
by the specificity,
that's interesting.
So, are you thinking of just
each player, what he brings
to the instrument
itself each time
or about convention no
ornamentation or treatise?
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Its -- at the end of the day,
it's much more a
question of understanding
that the exasperating fact
about playing any music,
particularly music from the 18th
century, is that my feeling is
that the difference between the
blue print that you're given
as the text, the black and
white dots on the page,
which convey rhythm and
pitch, and all this stuff.
The difference between
that and the end result,
is I would argue some of the --
a larger gap than possibly --
well, this is probably very
contentious what I'm going
to say.
But I think, I believe
in the case of Mozart,
that gap is possibly the
largest of any composer I play.
In the sense, that Mozart's
music is the least --
well, here's some examples.
When you play Bach, for
example, there's a huge amount
of abstraction that happens in
the presence of interpretation.
Which is not necessarily
conveyed in the notation.
But the notation doesn't
need to have it there.
With Mozart, the trouble is, if
you treat his music like that,
it sounds very boring.
Bach can be played a Moog
synthesizer and there's a kind
of incredible delight and magic
that happens as a
result of that.
But yes, we recognize the
dance references in his music.
The incredible symmetry, the
incredibly refined counterpoint.
Mozart sounds absolutely
unlistenable on midi.
And I think composers who
do require a lot more care
and effort and charm
and love and attention.
I think the 18th century
idea of what it means
to play a piece means to graft
your personality onto it.
I mean, this is why people
like Mozart and Haydn
and Beethoven veer
so dramatically
from their forefathers,
from Handel and Bach.
And that is, the act of
composition and performance
and reading the text
becomes a kind of triangle,
a trinity of acts, text
and acts, and performance.
And none of that is
really in the notation.
I mean you know what
articulations to play
and sometimes what
dynamics to play.
But really, to get to the heart
of the conveying the
rhetorical message
of the music is what
18th century --
late 18th century music
is all about, I think.
>> David Plylar: In
reconcile just a little bit.
One thing that I hadn't
mentioned is that you used
to play on multiple
keyboard instruments.
And if you trace, say,
across the lifespan of Haydn,
where he's writing for
specifically different types
of instruments over time,
his level of specificity
in his notation does
increase, I think.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: Yes.
>> David Plylar: How
does that interface
with what you were just saying.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: That's
such a good question, David.
Because I think what you see --
well, what David
says is so true.
Haydn has a career,
possibly the largest span
of any keyboard career,
in a sense.
Haydn is writing clearly
for the clavichord,
in certain repertoire.
Absolutely, he knows
the harpsichord.
He is also greatly
enamored of this piano.
He writes specifically the
chances [assumed spelling]
instruments were his absolute
favorite, over the kind
of south German, Viennese
style, five-octave instrument
that Mozart and Haydn knew at
this time, and also Schubert
in the early part of his career.
Then, of course,
Haydn goes to London
and plays the new-fangled
instruments in that city,
which are dramatically different
from the Viennese
instruments he knew.
I think what happens
with Haydn, for example,
you see in the London sonatas of
the early 19th century of Haydn,
that he starts, I think, writing
dynamics and articulations
that possibly indicate
in his mind,
what a Viennese player
must think of and do
when they're playing these
pieces on a London piano.
So, he writes lots of wedges.
And very interesting kind
of quite kooky instructions,
in a sense.
Incredibly weird and strangely
specific dynamic markings
that you very rarely see
in other Haydn pieces.
Then, at time, when you go back,
let's say 30 years and look
at works that might have been
conceived of and/or performed
at the clavichord, Haydn is
strangely lazy about details
of articulation in a way
that Mozart is never.
I mean, to the end of his days
Mozart will lavish attention
in matters of articulation
and become incredibly
lazy with dynamics.
And you see these different
priorities surfacing
at different times for
both of these guys.
I've never thought
of it quite like that
but it does really document
Haydn's current obsession
with that said keyboard
instrument that's
in front of him, perhaps.
>> David Plylar: Do you
think it has anything to do
with their playing styles
or performance styles.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Very much so.
I still don't know exactly
how to put that into words.
I think someone like Tom Baggen
[assumed spelling] would be able
to explain that really
eloquently.
But I think those connections,
the way the notation
is reflected,
reflects composes relation
to his keyboard instrument
at that time.
This is one of those sort
of secrets, Holy Grail,
elements of performance practice
that's yet to really be --
really brilliantly shown.
Because it's such a personal
covenant between player
and instrument, especially
now in this configuration
where we are playing in 2016-17,
on old instruments and trying
to recreate what we
know about the style.
And yet, it's a very,
very post-modern thing
that we're doing now,
playing these old instruments
in modern times.
But it's become so trendy
to hear performance of music
of the 18th century played
on period instruments
in modern times.
It's all just -- it's
kind of messy in a sense.
>> Anne McLean: Well, this for a
follow up further on the Haydn.
This is an unusual
piece that you're doing.
The variations.
How did you put this
program together
and how does it relate
to the Beethoven?
Also, David has some comments
on the octave writing in Haydn,
which is very unusual.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Absolutely.
This is a clear anomaly for
Haydn, this sub variations.
It's strange on so many levels.
Structurally, it's odd because
Haydn has this melancholy
wistful theme presented
in F minor.
And then a new theme,
binary theme,
which he presents immediately
after it, in F major.
And I think this is one
of those cases, times,
when you really realize
that people like Mozart
and Schubert were so deeply
impressed by Haydn's ability
to go back and forth between the
minor mode and the major mode
without any preparation.
And it becomes a real
trope at this time,
in the late 18th century.
That aside, Haydn chooses the
key of F minor for this piece,
which is a hugely
unusual choice for him.
I mean, we know he writes
symphonies in F minor.
F minor is described differently
by different theorists
at the time.
But the basic -- I think
the basic thing that you get
from F minor from almost
everyone is a sense
of loneliness and despair.
A kind of melancholy tragedy.
It's not the realm of C minor
or G minor, which for Haydn,
I think, and also for
people like Mozart,
have a much more brutal
kind of fate knocking
on the door characteristic.
This is music of unbelievable
introversion and introspection.
Curiously, then, you go along
with the set of variations,
which is very intimate
and kind of timid
and yearning and sorrowful.
And then Haydn does something
that you'll see later
in Schubert, for example,
in the A major sonata 959.
Where you have this
ostensibly very quiet, sad,
intimate structure or mode, or
rhetorical style established.
And then he just goes mad.
The music kind of
stops, as it were.
And descends into
complete fantasy.
Fantasy madness.
It goes into strange key areas.
It goes into D flat major,
which is a relative --
it is the relative
major of G flat major.
It's -- sorry, the
dominant of G flat major.
And then all of a sudden, you
have this outburst of kind
of tragedy and virtuosity.
Which then dies down again.
And then we return to
the barebones structures
of the original,
albeit, slightly altered.
It's a very -- it's kind of a
like a scenic kantarto,
this piece.
It reminds me a lot of
Arianna A Naxos, actually.
In the sense that that
it's charting kind
of mental breakdown
but then returns
to some order of semblance.
And it can't be any accident
that Arianna a Naxos starts
in E flat major, has an
aria in D flat major,
an aria in F major,
and by the end
of the piece it's in F minor.
And documents Arianna,
who is stuck on Naxos
and spends 20 minutes just
complaining about the fact
that her lover rejects
her and leaves her there.
That it ends in F minor in
this kind of world of madness
and feminine scorn and fury.
And I think F minor is very
deliberate choice for Haydn
in that sense, in this piece.
What I wanted to do as well,
was get these guys together
in way, Beethoven and Haydn.
Because Haydn goes to Vienna
and studies with Beethoven --
sorry, other way around.
Beethoven goes to Vienna and
studies with Haydn for a while
but it's not a great
relationship.
And it's very clear that
Haydn knows instantly
that this is an enormous
talent but, I think,
he feels very slighted
about the fact
that Beethoven never
really publicly acknowledges
that he is Haydn's student.
He dedicates music to him but
there isn't this sense of,
let me present a public
concert in your honor
or let me really
publicly acknowledge you
as my mentor and teacher.
And I think, in that sense,
when Beethoven studies
with Albrechtsberger he realizes
that he's got someone he
can control a lot more.
And Haydn doesn't really
do that for Beethoven.
I think it's very clear
that they have a kind
of jealousy towards each other.
Because they both know that
they do the same thing so well,
in a sense, and that is that
they have this uncanny ability
to take sometimes
the most banal,
kind of ridiculously crude
material and spin these motives
out in such ingenious
ways, often at the expense
of sophisticated
material to begin with.
I mean, I think sometimes
both Hayden and Beethoven,
if you really talk to them and
say, if you took to this kind
of material, let's say this
motive to your compositions,
[inaudible] said look I've
got this fabulous figure.
It's going to be the
source of inspiration
for the following 20, 5
to 10-minute movement.
They would all say,
well, that's madness.
This is not going to work.
On the other hand,
someone like Mozart,
goes to his composition
teacher and presents them
with five themes and they're all
just excruciatingly beautiful.
And the problem becomes, well,
maybe choose two of
them but not five.
And Mozart says, well,
no I'll write a rondeau
and I'll have five
themes that are just
of this incredible
characteristic beauty
and brilliance.
I think for both Haydn
and Beethoven the idea
of writing a melody that
can just sit by itself
and be completely at home
with itself, rhythmically
and melodically, is something
that exasperates
them a little bit.
And also, really
find counterpoint.
>> Anne McLean: As opposed
to your talking about Mozart
when he was able to do that.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Exactly.
That's my theory.
I mean there's this amazing --
496 is a trio, a
piano trio of Mozart.
And he writes a variation
movement.
And then I think the second
to last variation is a
[inaudible] variation
with invertible counterpoint
in it.
And Beethoven copies
this variation many times
with great exasperation,
you can tell.
Because he's sort of
saying like, ye Gods,
how is it possible that someone
like Mozart can absorb the style
of Handel and Bach
of having to getting
to know it sort of about 1782.
And immediately absorb
this deeply,
deeply sophisticated
contrapuntal possibility
into his own writing.
I mean, he does struggle
with it a little bit
in the Haydn quartets.
Interesting somehow.
That's sort of ironic, I think.
But Haydn and Beethoven don't --
they are jealous of
different things.
They're jealous of the
things they don't have.
And Beethoven is jealous
of what he sees in Mozart,
which is this effortless,
lyrical grace and counterpoint.
And, I think, this is my theory
and I think people will
argue with me a lot.
But I think Mozart is the --
is hands down the master
orchestrator of his time.
I think he gets a lot of
great ideas from Haydn.
And Beethoven does as well.
But I think the palette of
19th century orchestral sound
that we have, that really became
the standard sound is almost all
set up by paradigms that
Mozart establishes basically
from scratch, actually.
This idea of what the
wind band can sound like.
[Inaudible response] Absolutely.
I mean, Mozart comes up
with these ideas seemingly
from nowhere.
He starts writing for
the clarinet in this way
that is now completely
idiomatic to us.
But is really -- it really
comes out of nowhere.
He decides to write for
very specific instrumental
combinations like flute
and clarinet without oboes,
in the material piano concertos.
Questions of balance
and timbre between flute
and bassoon, for example.
And then vis a vie the
clarinet and oboe groups.
The way those groups interact
with the string sound.
This level of sophistication
is something that you see
in every single genre that
Mozart writes in, in the sense
that the orchestration
possibilities of every one
of those genre is
unsurpassed and seemingly
without previous [inaudible],
with the possibility
of a string quartet and
the symphony, obviously.
But from Haydn -- I'm
rambling here a little bit.
You should stop me.
[Laughter]
>> David Plylar: I want to come
back to something later about --
just more about the
program at large.
But speaking of your -- the
use of the word orchestration
and Haydn, in particular, I
know that you speak eloquently
about the way that one can
approach the fortepiano.
But I want to bring up
one technical aspect,
that I think is an example
of Haydn orchestrating
for his instrument,
in this case,
and that's the crossed hands.
And then that type of --
we'll see that in
several pieces tonight.
It strikes me thought, as I'm
used to hearing more of this
on modern piano, personally.
But it strikes me
as being much more
of a significant
gesture in that world.
Maybe you could speak
to that a little bit.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Absolutely.
The hand crossing
thing is a big thing.
Put it this way, in music for --
in music like sonatas
which is designed to played
in small settings,
i.e. not in public.
You see that composers
like Mozart and Haydn tend
to be quite conservative
in the technical demands they
play -- place on players.
Mostly because these
sonatas are not --
they don't imagine
these sonatas as works
for the future in a sense.
This is music that's designed
to be eaten up, devoured
by amateurs.
Very good players technically.
But Mozart doesn't write a
keyboard sonata with the idea
of playing it in public.
But the one thing that
he does always play
in public is sets of variations.
I'm just trying to highlight
the difference between public
and private in the 18th century,
which was an incredibly
strict divide.
Keyboard sonatas were
not played in public.
The fact that Mozart
played a violin sonata
with Regina Strinasacchi
at a public concert
in the 1780s is incredibly
unusual.
The fact that he plays the
quintet for piano and winds
at a public concert, to
which people buy tickets,
is super strange.
But at every one of these public
concerts, Mozart, for example,
who we know especially in his
blockbuster period from sort
of 1780, let's say, 3 to
6, always played a piece
of pure improvisation
in a concert.
Whether a fantasy, which is a
piece that has various themes
and sections strung together
or of said variations
on a well-known tune or an
original melody by Mozart.
And he would really do these
on the spot, institute live,
in front of an audience.
And then we're lucky enough
that he wrote them down.
But hand crossing, you only
see in Mozart variations sets
and in Mozart piano concertos
because these are pieces
that are designed
for himself to play.
So, they necessarily contain
the most virtuosic music
that you'll see in his career.
And I can tell you that the
technical demands versus,
from the variation sets
compared to the sonatas,
are enormously different.
And hand crossing, there's a
visual rhetoric involved in this
as well, which is what
David is bringing up.
Which I think is wonderful,
is that you actually see
the hands crossing over.
Which is something that 18th
century audiences, I think,
would have found absolutely
outrageously crazy to look at.
So, you've got the
visual element.
But the other thing is, if you
listen to a program like this,
bear in mind that the
five octave fortepiano
of the 1780s was seven keys
has very different sound
characteristics in
each register.
Because the striking
point is different
in every part of the piano.
So, the place where the hammer
hits the sting is very different
in the base, compared
to the tenor,
compared to the upper treble.
So, you've got this
kind of geography
and topography then established
by visually seeing the fact
that the hands are playing
in different places.
So, you can actually see
that they're doing that.
Which I think, really underlines
or underscores the fact
that the sound of those
registers is so different.
So, the left hand will be
doing its thing in the tenor.
And the right hand will
go to the extreme base
and then extreme treble.
And I think that's a real
kind of masterclass or expose
in how different those
areas of the piano sound.
So, you can hear it and
see it at the same time.
I mean, the idea of
Haydn to do that is so --
it's such a mind bender
because it's a variation set.
Which is ostensibly a public
genre for technical display
but it's in F minor
and it's andante.
And yet there's these tools
of virtuoso showmanship
that are incorporated into it.
Really fascinating
example of that.
[ Inaudible question ]
>> Could you repeat
the question?
>> Anne McLean: Would he have
played that ever himself?
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
I think probably --
I don't really know.
I'm very -- I'll admit that I
don't have a very strong sense
of Haydn, the person performer,
when I'm playing his music.
>> Anne McLean: I don't either.
You don't read much about it.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: No.
It's very hard to
know exactly what --
which of these pieces
he was playing.
Which of them he
sort of designed
for himself to play privately.
Pieces like the London Sonatas,
they were clearly not
meant for his performance.
Haydn is one of those guys
who is not really fettered
by the realities of playing.
A little bit like
Beethoven in the sense.
Where Mozart is deeply,
deeply concerned
with what's possible
on instruments.
Haydn doesn't really care.
And so, as a result
creates these kind
of fantasy realms
of possibility.
Which, again, I think,
why Beethoven is obviously
so attracted to Haydn's music
and the kind of deliberate way
in which it just
says, you know what,
your technical concerns
are of no interest to me.
We will make your instrument
do what I want it to do.
And you see this
in Beethoven, too.
On every on instrument,
in every genre.
The symphonies, if you talk
to period instrument players,
who play the symphonies
regularly on period instruments,
there is not a night
that they play a concert
of Beethoven symphonies that
goes by that they don't end
and say, it's an enormous
struggle to play this music.
[Inaudible response] Yes.
It's not just that
it's physically tiring.
There's this sense that
Beethoven asks you to do things
that require kind of
super human concentration
and physical coordination.
And if you hit, you hit
right out of the park.
But if you don't, it can
end in tragedy and disaster.
[Laughter] And Mozart
never, ever does that.
I have never once played a
Mozart piano concerto or sonata,
or a set of variations
where I have the feeling
that he's kind of taunting you.
And both Hayden and
Beethoven do that.
A lot. Possibly not deliberately
at the same time
but they both do it.
>> David Plylar: Can I
come back to something
that you were saying just a
little bit earlier, about --
you didn't say exactly this
but, basically, motivic parsing
versus say, spun melodies?
The pieces that we have
tonight, there's --
we have a lot of rondeaus
and literally rondeaus.
But also, different
types of development,
that I think are interesting.
And what I think -- I don't
know that this is worth talking
about differences or if
this is even important,
the notion of ornamentation
as a form of variation
versus other types of
developmental variation
that you might see in a sonata.
And of course, we
do have two sonatas
that we'll be --
well, three, I guess.
Haydn also called his a sonata.
[ Inaudible response ]
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: Just
in general or should we just .
. . Is that better?
>> Much.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: Okay.
So, we just need to
talk more into them.
Is that right?
This speaks -- it's a very
deep and serious question.
This speaks to a little bit
to what I was saying earlier.
This idea of trying to reframe
in one's mind what
people are doing
when they're playing publicly
in the late 18th century.
For the reason that we
know that there are tons
of really gifted professional
pianists at this time.
I mean, Mozart has
lots of students,
like Barbara Ployer,
for example.
These are very good players.
They can play anything
perfectly.
What sets them apart from
people like Mozart, particularly
and Beethoven 10 years later,
is that Mozart and Beethoven
and famous because they
are gifted improvisors.
So, they grew up with
contrapuntal training.
They can write fugues.
They can play continually.
They can improvise
fantasy, variation sets.
And that's what they're
being tested
on when they play in public.
Not if they can play perfectly.
And I think that's the first
thing, you have to understand
that that is the only reason --
the reason that Beethoven
becomes the celebrity pianist
of his generation.
And the reason that Mozart
becomes the celebrity pianist
of his generation.
There are others, of course.
There are people like Clementi,
who is also a similarly gifted
improvisor but when it comes
down to it those names really
emerge for very strong reasons.
So, you have to understand
that when Beethoven --
let's say that when Beethoven
is playing a piano concerto
in public, this is the first
time the Viennese public has
heard this piece.
And we also know that
what he's playing from,
the physical product in
front of him is a kind
of chicken scratch thing.
It's a few pages with very,
very rudimentary sketches
of what's going on.
And crucially, we know
that basically his brain knows
what's going on thematically,
clearly but the actual details
of the figuration in the moment
of performance are
left to that moment.
If you look at a piece,
like the 3rd piano concerto,
the way the piece has come down
to us in the source material,
it's complete and utter mess.
The same thing with
the B flat concerto.
There were wrong notes.
The passage work veers off
into strange directions
that haven't been corrected.
And I think the trouble is
we're hamstrung now by tradition
of word text perfection of
trying to get the source
in the best possible
state possible.
And I think in certain
repertoires that's kind
of impossible.
One of them being
a piano concerto.
It's very clear, if you look
at Mozart piano concertos
that the level of specificity
that he uses in writing a piece
that he prepares for
publication versus one
that doesn't get published, is
a difference of maybe 30 to 40%.
And it's my contention that
when you look at a piece,
a late piano concerto of
Mozart that he doesn't publish,
the level of information that
he can raise in the notation is
by its nature almost
half as detailed
as anything I think was going
on in one of those concerts.
It doesn't just mean that
he's improvising the cadenza
but the level to which he's
improvising ornamentation
on the spot, the level to
which he's changing figuration
from night to night, I think,
was a great, great deal greater
that what we're used to.
Even by period instrument
performers
who are really well
versed in the style.
So, the thing is you have
three things happening.
You have this piece of
paper in front of you,
which they're literally
playing from.
Mozart and Beethoven are
not playing piano concertos
by memory.
I think, they have some kind of
text that they're looking at,
interpreting, and
reading in a sense.
It's not a very detailed text
but it's providing
them information.
They have the text, you
have a composer reading
and playing the text,
and then you have the act
of actually bringing that
over to the audience.
And I think what David is
saying, which is fantastic,
is that ornamentation
is not seen
as a kind of optional extra.
It's a sort of emotional element
in the rhetoric of performing.
In the sense that
when the emotion
of the music becomes too
strong, you are forced
to ornament and decorate.
And that's why you see
in a Mozart piano sonata
when he prepares it for
publication, and he's got lots
of time on his hands, he'll
write out the ornaments
because he cares so
much about the quality
of that ornamentation being
conveyed to the amateur
out there who doesn't
know how to do it.
So, ornamentation becomes a
kind of structural element
in the actual emotional
content of the music.
And not a kind of, like glitter,
that you throw on one's stuff
to make it more beautiful.
So, as a result,
it really speaks
to how different these
guys are in their thinking.
I mean, I think I think Mozart
to his dying day, a melodious.
In the sense that he's thinking
of melodies as being presented.
And then altering those themes
or presenting other themes,
or making themes go
in curious directions.
Whereas Beethoven and Haydn
really are masters at this idea
of just taking the tiniest
building block, sometimes,
as I said earlier, when
it's presented to you kind
of grotesquely simple.
But what becomes so
fascinating is how,
especially you see
this in Mozart a lot.
You'll have these incredibly
tiny development sections
and then in Haydn and Beethoven
the development becomes this
place where they can really
show their genius in a sense.
Mozart sometimes suffers from
this problem where he says
to himself, well, my
themes are so fabulous,
what should I do here
in the development?
Okay, I'll just put three lines,
got through various
cord progressions.
I'll just take -- curiously
what Mozart does sometimes,
which is very strange,
he'll just take one kind
of virtuoso figure that he's
presented in the exposition
and he'll just circle it
through the circle of 5ths
or through some other kind of
interesting harmonics sequence
that he finds fascinating.
And it'll be very quick.
But then you see,
with Beethoven,
that he'll take this
very banal theme
and spend a long
time subjecting it
to a very intense development.
And I don't know to what
extent that was present
in the improvisations.
Because you see that
when Beethoven is writing
out improvised music, like
his cadenzas, they're sort
of kind of, 5-minute fantasies.
They're not that kind of
incredibly detailed motivic,
departures or explorations.
They're kind of free wheeling
virtuoso style fantasies
that present different sections,
much like a Mozart fantasy
or CPE Bach fantasy.
But I'm not getting
around to the question.
What was it, David?
[Laughter]
>> David Plylar: No, no.
This is more -- honestly,
you are hitting at
it from all sides.
Which is ornamentation as
a form of -- I don't know.
Maybe it's the intersection
between ornamentation
and recognition that a
rondeau has a built in,
kind of formal grounding point.
Yet, there's ways in
which it's buried often
with each occurrence and
then there's other ways
in which it's developed.
And what a sonata, look
at it as a development
but also there's this
developmental process that seems
to be going on each
of these works.
And it seemed like ornamentation
is also built into it.
And of course, it's built into
it even more carefully in the --
like in the pathetique.
You know.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout: Yes.
It's -- they do -- everything
happens sort of at the same time
but sort of differently.
You see that for Beethoven
-- look, put it this way.
For example, the
Beethoven rondeaus
that begin this program,
possibly the most perfect themes
that he writes in the
span of his career.
You see this very curiously when
Beethoven is writing rondeaus.
It's the same thing
with the two romances
for violin and orchestra.
They are possibly the most
exquisite melodies of their kind
from Beethoven's career.
And I think it's very true that
he's trying to replicate a sort
of apollonian Mozartian
melody style in those pieces.
And I'm sure, that if you really
sat down with blindfold and put
on something like the F major
violin romance, you would not be
at fault if you said, gosh,
that sounds like a theme
that Mozart would write.
And it's true of both of
these rondeaus as well.
There have been unbelievably
refined late 18th century grace
to them.
So, then you see that
Beethoven is at great pains
to write ornaments that are
incredibly sophisticated.
And I think, Mozartian in their
level of melodic, kind of,
horizontal beauty in a sense.
Some are like Haydn,
is interesting,
because the ornaments tend
to be very like kabuki-esque
if I could put it like that.
They have tiny, tiny imports.
They are trills, and then kind
of very tiny triplet materials,
hand crossing with sort
of little mini trills,
[foreign language] of five
notes in the right hand.
They're not very
melodic in a sense.
>> David Plylar: And that
get's reinterpreted so that,
say those groups of four
or five notes, are then --
instead of being part of a
turn or something like that,
they become part of the run.
And so they have a certain
resonance that goes beyond.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
That's true.
They become kind of
structural harbingers
of some kind of thing.
And then that's why, I
think, Haydn says, well,
I've been going through
this variation structure,
and I've been introducing
these discreet,
quite polite ornaments.
I mean, every variation set
in the 18th century goes
on the basic premise that
you present a variation
and you sort of exploit
one thing.
It's like, okay, here's
the trill variation.
Now here's the variation
with syncopations.
with hand crossing.
Now here's the variation
with whatever.
And then Haydn says,
okay, I've presented all
of these ideas discreetly.
And now I'm going to merge or
take myself into this world
of fantasy where all of
this stuff is presented
and then taken one stop further.
And he then introduces
new textures
that you simply haven't
seen anywhere in the work.
Mozart doesn't really do --
that's actually not true.
Mozart does two things.
He'll do variation
sets where he does
like correct, correct, correct.
Variation after variation.
And then you just get
the theme at the end.
And then sometimes he'll do --
now that I'm thinking of it.
He does this thing where he has
this sort of chord variation.
Which is much longer
and very virtuosic.
And often a capitula
[assumed spelling] as well,
where he'll stop
writing in bylines
and it'll become a
written out fantasy.
Probably that was -- who knows.
Haydn was an enormous
fan of Mozart.
This is very clear.
I mean, the respect between
these guys is something that --
between two people is
really deeply touching.
So, Haydn was probably at some
of these concerts in Vienna
and could have heard Mozart's
improvisatory abilities.
And was, obviously,
deeply impressed by that.
But it's true ornamentation
has this extra role,
added significance at this time.
It's not just something that you
read about in the [inaudible]
as a sort of optional extra.
It's something that the great
masters had to really do
in order to show their
incredible understanding
of the structure as well.
>> Anne McLean: This
is fascinating.
You know, it's at a level that
you don't usually get into,
these kinds of comments.
And it relates to this
rhetorical fantasy finale,
that's what David described
it as, in the Haydn piece.
[Inaudible comment] Sorry.
To leave that for moment but
to talk about the instrument.
Maybe it's a good time to
spend a little time talking
about how an instrument,
like we'll hear tonight,
allows you to bring
these to life
in your own way as a virtuoso.
But, you know, specifically
this piano is a copy
of a Shantz piano
from around 1800.
And it very much is
appropriate for this repertoire.
And If you could talk a
little bit about this one.
And also, a comment I read,
that you said, you're able --
if one is relaxed, one
can manage to bring
out an extraordinary degree
of lyricism in the fortepiano.
Which that's fascinated me.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
These pianos, yes, look --
these pianos live or die on
the tiniest, tiniest control
of what's going on at the key.
Let me just explain that.
because the fact is that all of
these Viennese style instruments
at this time, have a hammer
that is literally
attached to the key.
And so the activity of
the hammer is always,
always being controlled by
exactly what's happening
at the base of the key.
Now that's very, very different
from the leverage system
that was adopted in English and
French pianos at the beginning
of the 19th century, where the
increased weight and tension
of the instrument
meant that they needed
to find a leverage system
in order to cope with that.
So, the hammer is operated
then by an intermediary system
between what's going
on at the key
and what's directly being
transferred to the hammer.
And Viennese piano at this
time or a Shantz or anything,
you can take the
hammer out and the --
the key out and the
hammer is on it.
And everything that you do
at the key is transferred
without any delay or any lack of
focus or clarity to the hammer.
And I think that's why these
people, like Haydn and Mozart,
and also Beethoven, were so
obsessed with the immediacy
of Viennese instruments.
Is that there is no middle man.
Everything that you do is clear.
But it means, you've also got a
key that is remarkably shallow,
more than the modern piano.
And it takes much less physical
pressure to lower these keys.
But if you play with the
sound at the bottom of the key
with richness and
focus, not like banging,
but just very intense and
focus, like boney finger,
it can produce a very warm
and rich and focused sound.
But it's a little bit like
playing Schroeder's piano
from Peanuts at first.
It feels like you're
playing a computer keyboard.
It's a little bit
like the harpsicord
as well, when you're nervous.
It just feels very
surfacy and skatey.
But when you can relax,
you find that the sound,
that you can draw the sound
out from the instrument.
Rather than imposing
you're shoulder or kind
of late 19th century
physique on the instrument
to sort of make the sound.
The other thing is, there's a
kind of built in transparency
to this sound where there is
a marked decay that's present
in each note.
Which produces this sense
of space around the sound,
which allows you to
play faster tempos.
But not just that, it
makes the whole palette
of articulation much more dental
and speech like and rhetorical
and incised in a way, versus
this very cantabile idea
that we've become used to
with projection and density
of the modern piano sound.
>> Anne McLean: You
said something about you
like the ways these pianos
speak rather than sing.
I love that phrase.
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Thank you.
Well, they do.
It's a highly -- you know, it's
really no accident that people
like Mozart, especially,
are obsessed
with small scale
articulation in this period.
You see Mozart fussing endlessly
about how long slurs are,
where dots go, wedges
and all this stuff.
Haydn to a lesser extent.
Not because he's
not interested in it
but I think he's a bit
lazier about writing it down.
Beethoven is similarly
obsessed but you start to see
that the length of slurs
becomes ever longer.
But these guys have a set of
equipment that lets them do,
really, small scale
articulations really well.
So, their articulation
style, the house style is
by its nature, therefore very
short slurs, groups of two
to three, four, five notes.
None of the kind of
phrasing slurs that you see
in Schumann or Chopin later.
And these pianos do that
really well I think.
>> Anne McLean: Well, maybe
one question or comment
about the pathetique
chords and then I know
that you need a break
to get ready.
This piano seems ideally suited
in a way to those opening chords
of the adagio movement.
Can you perhaps say a little
bit about why that might be?
>> Kristian Bezuidenhout:
Beethoven writes seven note
chord in the pathetique,
the first chord of this piece.
And it crucially, very
unusually for the period,
contains both a third and
a fifth in the left hand,
in addition to the octave.
So, you've got a full note
chord played forte in the base.
Now anyone who's played a
piano of any kind realizes
that you do not write chords
of four notes with a third
and fifth in that part
of the instrument.
It sounds like murky,
swamp water, basically.
So, you see people
writing fifths,
sometimes isolated
thirds like that.
Normally, just octaves.
Mozart very, very rarely
writes chords like that.
and if he does, he normally
puts a line through them
or notates them in
his weird way,
that shows that he wants them
to be played arpeggiated.
Now it could be that's also
what Beethoven had in mind
with a chord like this.
We know that Beethoven is very
lazy about something like that.
And from his student
journey it's clear
that he expected certain chords
always to be arpeggiated.
And it's becoming clearer
that one of the cases
in which that's always
true is chords
like with thirds and fifths.
And that it becomes a kind
of emblem of the fantasy.
But on this piano, unlike
the Steinway, where I have
to be really careful
about voicing a chord
like that, not too loud.
Otherwise, it sounds
like amateur pianism.
Here I can just literally wallop
that chord with all the force
that I want and wait
for it to decay
because there's a strong
decay in the sound.
And then you can move on.
And I think that's part of the
characteristic of this piece.
It's just trying to up end what
happens in a keyboard sonata.
You're starting this
C minor sonata
with a French inspired overture,
kind of tragic and depressing,
in C minor with this hideously
inappropriately chord.
This is Beethoven, the kind
of grotesque, defiant one.
And I think it's a gesture
of disorder, and delight
and disorder, and descent,
and revolutionary quality.
And on this piano it
really sounds like,
this piano is about to break.
It can't take the import and
the intensity of what I'm
about to write for it.
And that sense of these
instruments being required
to life or death like, live
or die, on what they're asked
to do is such an important
aspect of this style.
And something that gets a
little ironed out, I think,
in the kind of utopian perfect,
everything uniform ideal
of the Steinway that we've
become used to in this music.
>> Anne McLean: That's something
to look forward to for tonight.
The extraordinary
sound that we'll hear.
And I think we have
to stop here.
But thank you so much, Kristian.
And we appreciate it.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.